it's not what we think it is and
sometimes when people tell me you know
oh psychology just common sense tell me
something I didn't know well I I got a
list and memory is one thing on the list
where a lot of people think what happens
in memory it's like you hold up your
iPhone and it's just recording the world
and also it stays in this hard drive and
then later on through hypnosis or a kind
therapist it could all come out it's
just there and this is total nonsense
what do we actually know about human
consciousness do we know why it evolved
or what its function is
no we don't know uh we don't know why
we're conscious as opposed to zombies
that are fully functional we don't know
um how the brain gives rise to
consciousness
we know it is a brain I mean the best
science tells us that that a conscience
emerges from a very physical brain but
one of the great puzzles in Psychology
is how this uh three pound piece of meat
bloody meat gives rise to you know love
and hate and the feeling of uh of a
first kiss and slamming your hand in the
car door and being on a podcast
um there's a lot we do know about
consciousness
we know um we know how how it uh we know
how it works in attention and perception
we we have theories of differences in
conscious experience but the big
questions at this point eludes
I've heard that one potential
explanation for the reason that
Consciousness comes about is that it's
kind of a byproduct of us being able to
have quite a complex theory of Mind of
other people that when you have a large
social group and I need to be able to
predict what Paul thinks about me
thinking about that person and what they
think about him thinking about me uh
that you end up having a lot of layers
of abstraction and that basically
Consciousness is potentially kind of
like a side effect like how a light bulb
gives off light but it also gives off
heat that all of the fancy mental
imagery that we get is just kind of uh
dressing on the side of that
I think it's it's possible one issue is
there's two senses of Consciousness at
least but too many people talk about one
is sort of what sometimes called access
Consciousness which is the idea of
information being available to us you
can monitor or we can analyze that and I
think that's really necessary for for
high level reasoning for language use
for making sense of of
um of what other people are doing so I'm
not right now directly conscious of my
blood pressure and heart rate it says
unconscious is fine but I'm conscious
that I'm talking to you and I know you
we met before and the fact that I'm
conscious of it means I can talk about
it I could reason about it and we have
good theories of that the more
mysterious thing is what's called
phenomological Consciousness the feel
and some philosophers think you could
have one without the other like we could
have we're going to be fully reasoning
and maybe AIS are like this or will be
like this where they have we're able to
reason and make arguments and have that
and and and and understand other people
other in people but um but the feel of
it the feel of being a person right now
to feel as you're sitting there of of
the seat against your behind the feeling
of headphones in your ears
where does that come from and that's
kind of a mystery and it may be epi
phenomenal or something else but then
you have to explain why is it Epi
phenomenal of that
what do you mean what's the word
epiphenomenal mean it means um that you
you have um a certain time of a certain
function and then something else comes
as an accident from it and what would be
another Epi phenomenon that humans have
to say one example is there's all sorts
of things about blood which are really
essential for what blood does but the
fact is the color red when brought into
the light is is that be phenomenal it
didn't have to be red it could be green
could be brown doesn't matter it's just
it's just there's no point to it
um I I learned the other day that there
is a particular genetic mutation in some
Asian people which causes them to have
both
I think it's low blood pressure and
extra dry earwax
anything yes so give me give me the
Adaptive reason so that's another that's
another example some people only stare
into the sun we'll sneeze
now what you know why yeah uh well
that's a good question I don't know
there's a story behind it but the story
Isn't Our Ancestors who did this
reproduce more than those who didn't
I mean I'm I'm as much of a fan of
evolutionary explanations as anybody and
and my book's full of them and you know
reasonable stories for perception and
sexuality and and reasoning but but when
it comes to the feel of Consciousness
some people say it's as much as much of
an accident
as as as the sneezing
I don't know one thing which is kind of
cool which isn't going to be any
interest in recently is how our
Consciousness differs and um so there's
people as you know synesthesia whose
senses flip over from one to another so
there's a there's a story of this
Russian guy who um who when he looks at
words tastes them and this is so much
you can't read the newspaper while he's
eating breakfast because it spoils this
meal you know
um then there's other people on The
Other Extreme who have I think it's
called a Fantasia no visual imagery
there's Wicked his guy on Twitter who
said I don't know if I have like 30 40
something like that way into his
adulthood says I always thought when
people said they have images in their
heads they were just it was just a
metaphor
but you know he had none You Close Your
Eyes nothing can't see anything
can't can't draw up anything
um some people have voices in their
heads I'm not talking about
schizophrenics I'm talking about sort of
a narrator
like in these you know in his comedies
or these these movies where there's a
narrating animal narrative some people
don't
maybe we experience pain differently
maybe we see colors differently that's
kind of cool
the fact that we're able to hear a voice
in our heads when we think it and you
think about uh interaction that you had
with someone an embarrassing one or an
enjoyable one or a loving one or
whatever and that you can hear a sound
but you can't hear the sound there's no
sound being played anywhere no that and
I think that this may be because my
I've heard that um certain people are
more image oriented uh other people seem
to be more whatever auditory oriented I
wonder whether there's some people that
are kind of more somatic like they feel
I wonder I don't know but for me I'm
definitely lean more heavily on hearing
the words hearing them spoken
me that loud they're really loud
sometimes and I think how can I hear
anything and they compete you can be
listening to something
actual sounds of actual words can be
coming into your ears and being played
to your brain and yet you can be hearing
your inner voice talk louder than real
words yeah yeah I don't you know there's
research with mental imagery that finds
that when some people people in in
laboratory terms create an image so they
ask you to sort of close your eyes and
think of the inside of your your house
or your apartment you know count the
windows walk around and count how many
windows there are you could do that
navigate around and everything now while
people do this their visual cortex is
activated
the same system that actually sees is
activated suggests in some sense you're
saying now I don't know if these Studies
have been done with with sound but it
wouldn't surprise me if the auditory
cortex was activated
you know you I can sometimes call to
mind not just voices but but music
chords for instance that you know and I
hear them as if I was hearing them
you talk in your new book about the
system of human memory and I think that
you've just nudged there on one of the
ways in which it could be a little bit
more fallible just how useless of a
system is the human memory construct
the human memory construct is
extraordinarily useful just just try
getting Amnesia and seeing how well it
works for you you know these disorders
where you you lose your memories of the
past or or these cases like these famous
case where people can't form new
memories is in the excellent movie
Memento Christopher Nolan's film this
guy can't form new memories
um but it's not what we think it is
when people tell me you know oh
psychology just common sense tell me
something I didn't know well I got a
list and and memory is one thing on the
list where a lot of people think what
happens in memory it's like you um you
you hold up your uh your iPhone and it's
just it's just you know recording the
world and then it also it stays in this
hard drive and then later on through
hypnosis or a kind therapist it could
all come out it's just there and this is
total nonsense
most of what we experience has lost
forever you don't intend to it just
doesn't get in and then when we recover
our memory when you say what happened to
you we talked a while ago how did that
conversation go where were you where was
I what was said
in somewhere you know we go back and we
there's a storage system there then
somewhere is a reconstruction
you know if uh if you said to me um said
to me boy that was quite a storm the day
we talked and then a week later he asked
me to remember to tell you about today
we talked you say I might say yeah it
was a storm wasn't there because what
you tell me fits it creates a story and
leading questions can create false
memories
you know there's a study after 9 11 a
couple of my colleagues
um came and they asked people where were
you when uh when the planes hit and um
these guys a bit older colleagues there
and uh and people gave their stories and
then they went back and asked them like
five years later Ten Years Later
and the stories are entirely different
we just we just our memories are deeply
unreliable
I'd heard a Bro Science rumor that
nothing is forgotten everything is kept
and it is a case of us unlocking that
you're definitively saying that that's
horseshit worship
how do you know it's horseshit
it's horseshit in a couple ways one way
is that some things that extend you
experience that you're sort of right in
front of your eyes you don't attend to
them most of the world you don't tend to
you tend to like a percentage of the
world if you don't tend to it it's not
that gone six months later it's gone
five seconds later what do you mean when
you say attend to it
so
it was a wonderful experiment then as
Classics around people probably have
heard of it before we want everyone to
watch a film and um and you get them
there's going to be people wearing
different color t-shirts and tossing
basketballs back and forth and you ask
them at the end of the film how many
basketballs are tossed and how many
times there's a toss and you'll say oh
was it 18 was it 17. that's not what a
study is about the trick is that in the
film somebody with a gorilla suit walks
into the middle pounds his chest and
walks out and people don't notice even
though in front of their faces and and
because their attention is drawn one way
the rest world is invisible to them in
fact they came to a book called
Invisible Gorilla summarized by by uh
Dan Simons and Chris chabri and you're
not going to remember the gorilla
because you didn't attend to it
if you don't focus on something that's
gone so that's one way it's horseshit
the second way is there's just no
evidence for this sort of perfect
recording
people the reason why that this I guess
bro science things come up is you kind
of feel that way you feel oh my God I
photographed memory remember exactly
what it is I can recreate it exactly and
people have memories that are are
confident and powerful and genuine and
false
so and and I think we we mistake the
confidence for the reality
and then this by the way this by the way
so much of my book is sort of
theoretical stuff which I think is
really cool but but not a much practical
way business practical value because of
eyewitness testimony
somebody somebody sits on a on a witness
answer that was the man who attacked me
and they point to somebody and juries
here it says well wow
that's that's sincere I can't that can't
be wrong the person's so confident
people are confident
then you do a DNA test or you check back
and a person didn't do it
and so now we have a better
understanding of the weakness of
eyewitness testimony we're particularly
bad when it comes to other races
recognizing and remembering their faces
and and you know so there's a practical
value of knowing this
I remember learning
before I even started this show about a
study that was done on babies
when they were young being shown
different images of sheep and what the
babies would do because they hadn't
learned to
condense together all sheep faces into
just a sheep that they were paying more
attention because they could see that's
one sheep that's another sheep but a
different sheep that's a third sheep
different to the first two whereas and I
think it was maybe around age either six
months to a year or so that they lose
that ability presumably the same way
that I always heard that we could wiggle
our ears but because the muscles don't
get used they atrophy away I I heard I
might be just spouting total
Bro Science at you today
um
I heard that that is a similar system
that's online as to the reason as to why
we struggle more so with different races
to be able to pick their faces apart do
you think that that sounds accurate
it might be
um you you can use in some ways babies
are the perfect you know amateurs they
they don't have experience in anything
well we are her amateur in some way
versus other ways
um
sort of so sort of story for ad I'll
tell you the story for adults you can
tell me if it connects to the baby story
the story for adults is it's the race
event has nothing to do with your own
race it's just who you had the most
experience with
so if I if I see 10 000 white faces and
I regularly have to distinguish them
more or less maybe for like 100 of them
I get very attuned to small differences
just like just like if you're really
into
um I don't know
um classic rock
you'll distinguish this Pink Floyd song
from that Pink Floyd song This Zeppelin
song that Zeppelin song but if you don't
have much experience or interest in
something it all blurs together oh
that's more classical
you know or that's another Asian face
that's another black face I can't pull
them apart
and so it's a matter of sort of
discrimination with expertise and their
faces are just like songs they're just
like Foods they're just like wines
um when you zoom in on something you get
better at it but then when you're in a
sort of separate domain you're not used
to you get worse at it does that sound
like the baby thing yeah I think it I
think it is and what it highlights is
that the race of the person that is the
viewer has basically no yeah uh impact
on their ability to see the people it's
yeah it's very much kind of like
training it's training data right
foreign
look at white people black babies then
prefer look at black people but it's not
again it's not their own race it's just
it's just you get a familiarity
preference you like to look at what
you've seen before and we know that
there's an Israeli study that uh looks
at kids race and sort of a Cosmopolitan
environment a lot of black people white
people around they show no preference
and again it doesn't matter what color
the baby is it's just they're training
data
when it comes to uh biases that are uh
trained heavily seems slightly less
inbuilt uh humans are incredibly tribal
do you think that we have a
predisposition to a small amount of
racism in all of us
I think tribal's a great word here
racism carries some extra baggage so I
wanted I've never noticed that racism
carries a little bit of extra package
you've heard it you've heard it before
have you heard that it's a fraud issue
you're not of this country are you so
it's not it's um no um so yeah Bible
humans predisposed to be tribal I've
I've written about this and people have
summarized it it was a gawk here like
babies are a little racist it's not
quite true and in fact it's not quite
you in an interesting way we're very
tribal but here's a cool finding from
the babies from the baby work and
toddler
babies show strong preferences very
early on H1 h2h3 into who to interact
with who to take a toy from who to
accept food from and they've done these
experiments where babies I would say a
white baby is given something by a white
person or black person and they have to
choose and the cool finding is up to a
certain point they don't care about
color
they recognize color they notice color
they have a preference sometimes look
they just don't care about it they care
deeply about language
so and it's not just you you should have
a baby raised in the states they have
them a black person speaking English
offering them a toy and a white person
speaking French uh offering them a toy
they'll choose it from the black person
speaking the French the French it's
not specific to it but not racist we're
not racist against anybody except for
the French you're taking this to to uh
too literally yes yes they hate the
French there we go that's what I want
people to take from my book
you know I will say something actually
pro-french which is they did a study a
while ago where um where they exposed
babies born in France to um to either
French or Russian
and babies prefer to listen to French
so they concluded in this innocent this
is this is a story I heard from the
researchers it may or may not because
but it concluded well you like to listen
to the language you exposed to early on
the The rhythms resonate through the
womb and everything like that and then
some reviewers said what if Francis
sounds better period
for everybody so they had to go do this
study in Russia and then they found
Russian kids preferred Russian to French
so it's not that there's a universal
preference uh the very idea somebody
would say that is just a bit of
pro-french to respond to your
anti-france right rightly so that's fine
we've balanced it out the French people
are still listening
um I
also was uh looking at a study from
uh who's the guy that wrote this
psychopath book British dude that lives
in Australia
no no no no no no no uh his
name's escaping anyway him
um and uh what he what he was saying was
how uh people have massive Prejudice
much much greater than between skin
color for different accents and this
would be adaptive because typically
ancestrally you would not have been
exposed to people of different skin
colors I mean what the where have
you ended up that you've seen someone
with a different skin color in you know
2000 BC but someone from the next Valley
who says a couple of vowels in a
slightly different way that's somebody
that you should be very very cautious of
and uh yeah you know it makes so much
sense and I really really love that
Insight
um which was one I'd never thought of
before which is if somebody of A
different race with the same accent as
you walks into the room you feel like
you have so much in common with that
person if somebody of the same race with
a different accent what into the room it
is of it is straight just so in your
face and obviously you go oh you're
gonna you're gonna be a little while
before we got to find common ground for
us to talk about
and that's the argument the argument is
like the the psychopath guy is he a
psychopath or does he study Psychopaths
studies psychic he may also be a
psychopath but he seemed quite quite
nice so okay
um the the point is that that from sort
of an Adaptive point of view from a
historical point of evolutionary you
would expect language to be a wonderful
cue to US versus them and babies seem to
think that way now later on you pick up
whatever tribal whatever whatever counts
as US versus them in your Society so if
you're in Ireland at a certain point
it's one thing if you're in Israel it's
another thing if you're United States
it's another thing so at some point you
start to realize that wow US versus them
in my Society May well be race May well
be skin color
and that might really matter
a lot
um and in fact for adults at least there
are three things we focus on
um when we look at a new person there's
things that stick in memory things that
really count
sex gender like male female age matters
you'll remember whether you're talking
to a baby or an adult or an old person
or whatever and race
but race is in some way to odd man out
race is unlike the other two things race
might take on significance as you're
being raised in a society or Race
Matters if you go to a society where
Race Matters less
maybe not because they're Angels but
because they focus on linguistic
differences or something else then then
you won't be as attuned to it
that's interesting I um just rounding
out that conversation about memory
what does it suggest about uh
um what we should do how our attention
system works what people should do if
they feel bad about their memory and
remembering things that
stuff that isn't attended to is so
easily forgotten
yeah yeah
um nothing you kind of stuck to it that
the funnel of attention is very limited
so I mean it would be maybe a bit of
concrete advice there's a couple of
concrete device pieces of concrete
advice one is you can choose what you
attend to
but if you want to remember what people
wear when you talk to them focus on what
they wear but you have you can't expect
it to get into the system without making
it through the sort of the sort of
bottleneck of attention so you need to
you need to attend and people who are
skilled at that sort of thing like um in
some way Radiologists who are looking
for signs of cancer or air traffic
controllers monitor introductory a lot
of the training is what do you attend to
if you put somebody who does who never
played football
um and and and they're all of a sudden
they're playing game of football they
don't know where to look they don't know
this counts and that counts you know
they're looking at people's hairstyles
or looking at you know watching the the
ice cream truck roll by you know there's
certain part of becoming experts I think
is knowing what to attend to
now
putting that aside their our memory
techniques
um when I taught my intro psych course I
had a Joshua IV come in and give a guest
lecture he wanted you he's a writer he
wrote a book called moonwalking with
Einstein where he outlies the sort the
historical the classical memory
techniques where you basically got to
make Vivid associations between things
and you know with a couple of hours of
training you could learn to do really
powerful tricks of memory but here's the
thing and he gave me permission to tell
the story which I tell in my book he he
gives this bang of lecture in my class
about memory techniques students love it
um I get an email from him
um like a couple of hours later saying
uh dude I left my phone in the class
because he doesn't have good normal
memory that sort of stuff you can't
train
wow yeah I am I have a bunch of friends
who were medical students Anki ebbing
house forgetting curve space repetition
all of that uh Peter C Brown that wrote
make it stick was like episode 20 on the
show I think and um
yet we do things like leave our keys
yeah and yeah meet someone and as they
are telling us their name forget the
name forget the first half of the name
as they speak the second half of the
name because our mind is just somewhere
else yes and they're right and that's
actually a really good example which is
which is you want to remember people's
names you got to make a freaking effort
you know Chris and then I sort of I see
your and there's all these techniques
which sound we do I see your face and I
imagine the sea around us I don't know
but but which I'm I'm horrible at that
but um names you could use techniques
faces are tougher and that's actually an
enormous difference are you good with
faces
not bad as a uh club promoter for a long
time that was something that was pretty
good for me but what's worse is being
good with faces and bad with names
because what the does it mean to be
good with faces like I've met this
person before which is even more Awkward
for you to say well I suppose it
mediates you going hi nice to meet you
and they say oh we've already met but
it's only half a step away from high
with I know we've already met and I
forgot your name
I am so so bad at both faces and names I
have said good to see you in the hopes
that it's ambiguous between medium for
the first time and and meeting them and
having oh you're hedging your bets
you're hedging my Betsy
well okay so true story well I was at
yeah we had a party for incoming
graduate students uh to try to lure them
into into coming into the program we had
a party in our house and I go up to
somebody and I say you know hi it's
really uh it's it's really nice to meet
you welcome to the Andy steering me says
I've been in a graduate program for
three years here
and since since then you know it's and
it's not
I don't know there's this enormous
variation we have to forgive forgive
each other and mostly me for for things
out of our control
okay being bad at faces is the thing I
know very little about Freud my
um
completely self-taught psychology
experience has almost exclusively missed
out everything that he did how much of
him should anybody be taking seriously
now in 2023 so first I bet you know more
about Freud then then you think you do
because Freud has sort of trickled into
modern culture so if you've ever heard
somebody say to somebody else you know
you know look I'm not your mother or he
has an anal personality
or you know something like that these
are Freudian ideas
I don't think you need to know anything
specific about Freud's theory because
for the most part it's wrong
that the details the oral stage the anal
stage of phallic stage the edible
complex the Primal scene the idea that
for every kid the most pivotal moment in
our life is when they see their parents
having sex or fantasizable it's a lot is
just just nonsense you think a lot of
this was just projection from him
no I think that's there's
he was actually I think he was not a
nice man uh he he was vicious to his
enemies and sometimes to his friends and
he was ruthless in his Pursuits he was
pretty seemed psychologically normal in
many ways um I do think he was a genius
really wonderful writer brilliant
scholar what what it was was very much
of a construction of his time
which was extraordinarily repressed
about sex
and um and people really did come in
with bizarre hysterical symptoms for
instance that may well have been rooted
to sexual repression
um there were issues of he struggled his
whole career making sense of stories of
sexual abuse that women told him at one
point believing they were real and then
then they and then later on saying that
they were they were fantasies by these
women and struggling with that but
wherever his views came from they have
nostal disaster time with the exception
of the most important thing at all of
all which is Freud Champion more than
anybody else the idea that we have a
dynamic unconscious that
um what we think and what we do who we
who we fall in love with who we vote for
who we hate when we make mistakes when
we miss an appointment we were set up to
do
um he would view all of this as
generated by factors that are not
conscious to us that we're not aware of
and this idea he wasn't the first but he
was the one developed most this idea I
think is right
like sometimes I do political psychology
or moral psychology people say you know
we're really interested in why people
vote voted for Trump or why other people
voted for Biden well you're not going to
find out by just asking them
because it's not that they lie to you
though they'll do that too is that they
don't know
we don't know you you know we tell
narratives I can say so you have a very
popular podcast how did you get into
what made you did it and you don't have
a story that's what we do we have
stories is your story true probably not
probably the answer to a lot of stuff is
stuff you're not aware of
and Freud was the first to sort of make
such a thing about it and there he was
right there's like a thousand a million
psychology studies that support the idea
were driven by it unconscious that's all
you need to know about Fred
that suggests something that I meant to
say earlier on about the eyewitness so
the eyewitness erroneously points the
finger at Paul and said it's him it's
him that forgot my name and stole my
lunch and then the DNA evidence of her
lunchbox shows that it wasn't you it was
me and everybody then points at the
eyewitness and says willful deception
she was trying to pin it on Paul because
she had a thing and he got no no no it
is possible for you to fully believe
what it is that you're saying like the
way that the memory system works allows
you the the best way to deceive someone
you're trying to deceive is to believe
it yourself
yes I mean I guess and that gets us into
a really other another interesting topic
which very much dovetails on on Freud
which is why are some things unconscious
in the first place and the standard
story as well Consciousness is limited
you know if unless somebody needs to be
conscious
better to keep it out of out of the
system so this is why we're not
conscious of our blood pressure we're
not conscious of our of our our body
temperature uh our heart rate we can
infer them from other things we don't
have direct access to them and maybe
this is true for all sorts of things
you're not conscious of all these
systems going on your head but the great
evolutionary theorist Roberts who's
still around
suggested that there's another reason
why something might become unconscious
and this is your reason which is
deception
which is sometimes
um the best way to fool somebody else is
to fool yourself
so
um imagine so take confrontations you
know I'm in a conference a physical
confrontation with somebody and
everything and and I wanna I also you
know want to act like oh you know I will
not back down I will kill you coming to
closer I'm fearless
and I believe it myself even though I'm
not
but to convince the other person which
is what I'm really after what the system
what the system works is it's really
good to believe in yourself and the
other example is falling in love
where sometimes the system what's the
best way to convince somebody your head
over heels and levels now you'll never
leave them you're totally into them well
to believe it
and having ulterior motives like a sort
of one well if this doesn't work out I
have plan B having that not available to
your Consciousness is a wonderful way to
see a lot of people
one of the interesting things about the
love example is I actually don't know
what the difference is between believing
that you're in love with somebody and
being in love with somebody in the
eyewitness example we have a real world
and then we have an experience and we
can compare those two right the DNA on
The Lunchbox in this scenario
I don't know what it would mean for your
mind to for my mind to kid me that I'm
in love with you when I'm not yeah
I I don't know how that would differ
in a lot of ways it would overlap and
it's hard to see the believing you're in
love with somebody and being in love
with somebody pulling apart too much but
you could imagine that you believe it
but at another level you're constantly
hedging
and that there's there's a caution to it
imagine
um imagine you're getting you're about
to you're about to bond with somebody
I'll never leave you and you believe it
totally and then all of a sudden you
know a part of your head clicks let's
get a prenup
where did that come from and the fact
that that comes to my name is Jesse you
really don't there's part of your head
that's kind of looking towards other
things
I mean one of the findings which I kind
of like it's just kind of sweet is you
ask people who are about to be married
what are odds of you getting divorced
and they'll often say zero one percent
two percent tiny what are those of
somebody else getting divorced yeah
fifty percent
but not me
and you see that's kind of nice
kind of
supporting what you're saying that that
sort of over optimism is part and parcel
of of what it is to be in love
you know if you really thought it was 50
that's not a good sign
even though that's what that that sort
of cold-blooded uh uh math says
but I wonder if at some level you
believe that you don't believe it some
level we hedge these things
what do you think intuition is
so there's many answers to that here's
an answer which I like it's from Danny
conleman who won the Nobel Prize and and
talks about two systems of the Mind One
called system two is the rational
deliberative system I think this is
extremely important I think it's what
separates us from other creatures where
we we plan we we do cost benefit
analyzes the other one is system on our
gut a gut Works metaphorically on God
fast intuitive quick
um our system two could be egalitarian
our system one's almost always racist
our system two can do the math our
system one goes with whatever options
there I think system wants the gut
and we have system one for a reason
it's really free sometimes we need to
move quickly
sometimes the statistics are the way to
go you don't want to work its way
through but despite what some people say
it's not always right and sometimes you
want to distrust your gut I was once
asked for a while if I would um would
put up a billboard that could say
anything what would I say and I after a
while I said don't listen to your heart
and I think our our heart our gut
feelings often are are right within a
narrow range but let us down for a lot
of things
what's a better approach then
deliberation
rational deliberation
with the help of others because because
we're really kind of sometimes awful
deliberators when I make a decision and
I start thinking about it I'm often
thinking well let's explore all the ways
in which I'm right
but if you have good friends you talk
about and say well I'm thinking of you
know of leaving this person I'm thinking
of of getting a new job I think I'm
moving here and I'm really enthusiastic
with and then your friends will say well
let's let's work this out
and and I think that that sort of if you
if you have the time if you have if you
have more than like 10 seconds to act
you have some time deliberate and it's
like it's like science it's like it's
like politics at its best it's like
culture where smart people different
views getting together can bring you way
more than you can as an individual
I wonder whether I'm seeing a trend at
the moment of people being too
deliberate with their decision making uh
I think
maybe maybe I'm wrong but certainly a
lot of my friends out here in Austin I
think uh could actually do with a little
bit more intuition could actually do
with letting go of some of the
deliberate cerebral cognitive horsepower
that they're applying to some of the
decisions that they go through and that
they're moving more slowly that they're
vacillating they're talking themselves
into and out of decisions that are bad
and good for them
um and I wonder whether I don't know I
mean this is me totally Bro Science in
you here but um
a lack of embodied practice a lack of
movement time outside where you're not
just doing the thinking thing more
people have got knowledge worker jobs
than ever before and also
for the first time in history your
opinions are more important than your
Deeds now you know it's not really about
what you do it's about the takes that
you have and I wonder whether that is
causing people to self identify with
their thoughts more than with their
feelings and body
yeah so I'm I'm a a pro rational guy and
I've I sort of like so I'm inclined to
like disagree with you on that but I'll
give you two reasons why I think you're
right our two cases where you're right
one is for certain things
um you don't want to deliberate you want
to go for your gut and everything an
obvious example is if you're a really
good tennis player just return the back
end don't sit down and think about it
make a diagram really it'll mess you up
and in fact for for really good athletes
thinking about it kills them
thinking about it has led to people's
careers being destroyed where else and
they said you know what is it like to
catch a fly ball
you know what do you know how does it
feel to throw a punch is this the right
way is it this way is it this and you're
You're gone because you have to let the
body do it let the gut system do it and
some things are probably like that for
people if you're good
if you're socially Adept and someone
says something in a party you may be
some repartee or maybe an argument go
your your gut is better it's
statistically better than the rational
system that's one case another case is I
think our intelligence when employed
properly could bring us to places that
our gut never can and I think it really
is how to handle good good choices I
don't think you should decide to get
married in a split second I don't think
you should quit your job because you're
just really in the mood to do that but
sometimes and you actually said this a
rational system all it is is uh um it
defends your initial gut feeling
Jonathan height has this this line where
I disagree with him in General on this
but I think he's quite wise he pointed
out a possibility which sometimes our
deliberating minds are like lawyers not
like judges so it's not like it's a
judge balance a good judge balances
things that make decisions a lawyer
takes something it makes a case for it
and if that's what your rationality is
being used for do less of it
at the other end of the spectrum to
Freud would be Skinner in his
behaviorism
he also seems to have become a little
bit or quite a lot less popular recently
what what's why is behaviorism being
sort of thrown away I thought that was
pretty locked up it's deservedly so so I
have a lot of love for Freud I have no
love for Skinner I met him once though
when he was old he gave a talk is it you
know he had an enormous influence on
psychology and
his Insight was these it was developing
he wasn't the first development but
building on this theory of basic
learning mechanisms classic conditioning
sort of Pavlov thing you know you hear a
dentist dwelling and he Flinch you know
you see a commercial for some delicious
food your mouth Waters but also operant
conditioning rewards and punishment is
how we train animals it's very useful
but Skinner was very Skinner was in some
way I'll put this in the most offensive
way possible let a strange cult
where you could only look at what people
did and their their inputs and you can't
talk about their internal States
some behaviorists would say that's just
not scientific to talk about memories or
beliefs or desires dreams ambitions
others would say these don't exist at
all
we did we're just behaviors everything
nothing else input yes
there's a joke about um two behaviors at
a conference they have sex and one of
them says to the other one was it good
for me
and the idea is to explain the joke
there's no such thing as monitoring your
own States oh you got it here is your
behavior
um and that's so weird of course
whatever my complaints are with the AI
movement they get something really
important right which is that that you
can't explain and program complex
Behavior without putting a lot of
Machinery inside statistical analyzes I
think also rules memory bases and so on
and you know Skinner thought that is a
little unscientific I think the fact the
existence of computers has shown that
building machines will stuff inside and
trying to explain the stuff inside is
how you do good science of intelligent
Behavior
and it's how psychologists do their
stuff
are we losing something by
casting off the insights of behaviorism
in the modern world
it's a good question
um I I I think sometimes Skinner gets it
right
um
the time I think about Skinner the most
so Skinner was uh one of his nice ideas
was that of intermittent reinforcement
an idea is if I want to make you learn
to do something quickly I'll reinforce
you every time but you could be a you it
could also be a rat or a pigeon I'll
reinforce you every time
but suppose I want you to do something
forever I want you to stick with it then
I randomly reinforce you rarely and then
and then you start getting in the
behavior and because you don't expect a
reward every time it's always coming up
next you can't stomp yourself
I've never been tempted by slot machines
which was Skinner's favorite example but
like a lot of people social media gets
me and uh and you know so three in the
morning I wake up I decide isn't it a
great idea to check my phone and check
Twitter this is perfect brilliant idea
so so and then I spend an hour flicking
my finger up oh that's nice
and then this intermittent reinforcement
and I'm like I'm like a rat in Skinner's
cage and so much of the sort of
addictive techniques that people in
Facebook and Twitter use are straight up
Skinner
so you know
I'm not a fan but we ignore them at our
own peril yeah interesting you know
Diana Fleischman evolution of psychology
personally but I like her work yeah
she's got a book coming out called how
to train your boyfriend and she's I
think she's terming it evolutionary
behaviorism that she's trying to use EP
to inform uh that back and forth that
you that you do have and I you know
Peterson's touched on this a little bit
where he says you know if your partner
does something that you want them to
keep on doing make sure that you
remember to praise them about it that's
not exactly rats in a cage that just
feels a little bit more like not being a
human but yeah
and people so so there's an insight
there but people are complicated in a
way so suppose you want your kid to read
let's take it away from that more
interestingly enough sex and let's get
boring here we want your kid to read so
what's gonna we'll give them every time
he reads a book give him 20 bucks
certain age gives us a lot of money
because oh my gosh this is great
um and he'll read books
um but the argument against this is
his ultimate view will be books don't
have any intrinsic value
like a rat's never going to think this a
rat's gonna gonna bang away at whatever
you you put in front go down shoot down
to maze for the reward it will never
think going down this maze is kind of
futile it's just for it's just for the
reward it has no interest in fact but
people will do that people will do that
and you know imagine imagine for for
either of us getting some sort of
monetary award for doing something
you might do it if the money's big
enough but you but the minute the money
goes away you'll stop
sometimes for people
it's almost the opposite where the way
to get people to Value something very
anti-fraud it's a anti-skinner it's the
is to get them to pay for it
so so therapists say with some
justification if the clients don't pay
they don't take this seriously
um commitment advice exactly exactly uh
politicians like volunteers now they
like volunteers that are cheaper but
they also like volunteers because after
you volunteer for politician you're
using oh my God I really believe in this
while after doing it for fifty thousand
dollars a month they think I'm doing it
for the money who cares for the
conversation so this is a way in which
operant conditional logic of it I'm not
sure you want to reinforce your
boyfriend for something
um if you want him to do that thing
uh when a reinforcement goes away
interesting that'll be very very
fascinating I I I totally understand
what you mean there's always these
stories about
um
parents trying to use reverse psychology
on kids to get them to want to eat
vegetables like oh unless you're good
you won't get any vegetables and then
have you seen have you ever looked at
any of this stuff is that legit does it
work
um nothing works but but this is one of
the lessons like that nothing works but
the logic the logic is is is right
um look my next project uh after this
this book is I'm very interested in
perverse desires I'm very interested in
why people do something because it's bad
I have a TED Talk coming out on this
next week and it's like it's it's and
there
the the draw is the Badness what's an
example of a bad
the classic example which is Saint
Augustine in the confessions one day he
and his friends go into an orchard and
they just start stealing the pears
they're not hungry they throw them away
they throw them to pigs actually
and um and I am and when Augustine's
like shocked at this this isn't a story
he says I'm going to say the stories of
sexual debauchery but then he says I
understand my sexual debaucheries
reinforcing as you know Skinner would
say why did I do this he said because it
was wrong because I shouldn't have done
it so then I started a thing called a
perversity project where I started this
webpage and I got people to tell me send
me stories of things that they did that
were perverse in that way and my
favorite stories this guy this guy's a
young guy says I never was with my
friend and we each order an ice cream
we're walking down the street and
suddenly I get this urge and I Jam my
finger into his ice cream and and my
friends says dude why'd you do that and
and the guy's ready said I didn't know
but I said I just thought for a second
it'd really be up if I stuck my
finger in this ice cream
and this is very non-skinarian thing but
but the designers and just because it's
really up not despite it but just
because this is a powerful word
when it comes to development we talked
about babies and stuff earlier on have
you got any idea how much babies
actually know yeah that's one of the
that's one of the great discoveries of
psychology I've been lucky enough to be
acquainted with workers and people who
are real made these these great
discoveries like Elizabeth spelkia and
Harvard for instance
um
baby is no surprisingly a lot about the
World by the time they hit about their
first birthday you could test in subtle
ways and you finally understand
the physical world and they're not they
could reason about gravity they
understand what an object goes out of
sight it Still Remains they reason about
how things move by contact they also
understand a social world
they know that if one person helps
another person the person who's helped
will later go back to that person uh who
helped them
they know they have one person messes
with another person the person who got
messed with will avoid that first person
sometimes attack them
and you do these incredible research
programs showing that very early on we
seem to be hardwired with some rich
understanding in the world so people
like Plato and Kant and Chomsky I think
are been Vindicated by the science and
developmental psychology and the idea to
mind is a blank slate has been proven to
be wrong
what do you mean
pre-programmed
it means that
just like every other animal starts with
certain instincts about the world some
basic understanding of the world to
varying degrees maybe they already know
how to communicate maybe they already
know how to move around
um we're no exception
so we come in the world in some ways
tremendously behaviorally helpless
babies are extraordinarily vulnerable
for a long period of time then there's
again an argument that this is because
you need a long period of time for
development because with such social
cultural creatures there's an enormous
period of helplessness
and then an enormous period of waiting
before sexual maturity just to get the
system all up to speed just to do the
the the the learning that has to be done
but in addition to the capacity to learn
I think Evolution has wired up us up
with a pre-programmed understanding of
the world
some things don't have to be learned
wow I so
I was thinking about this before I was
walking around the park that's next to
where I live and I saw a dog and it does
its business and then it does that back
leg flecking thing which I mean it just
it wasn't even facing in the right
direction it was pointless but I always
wonder who taught the dog to do that
did watch other dogs is it a reflex like
putting your hand on a hot stove
for a lot of the behaviors of animals
including really complicated behaviors
more complicated than that
um I think they're just born with it
now animals differ some animals pop out
and they're basically adults they're
basically they know everything other
animals there's a long period of
learning and for other animals is kind
of a compromise so bird song for
instance is partially innate but then
depending on the community of birds
you're raised in it will all do a bit of
learning like like learning English
versus French versus Korean whatever
um I think for humans there probably are
not that many
um inborn behaviors a few you take a
baby you think it's time you put your
hand the baby will grip stuff like that
would you we were once we were once you
know hairy animals that are and there's
a bit of a of a connection with that so
we have a few behaviors like that
but I think most of the stuff is just
pre-wired understanding of the world
you know my favorite thing uh uh uh
effect that we have that's vestigially
carried over from our time as primates I
learned this from Robin Dunbar and uh
it's the stroke response that you get
and there is a maximum and a minimum
speed that your finger needs to move
across someone it's around about three
centimeters per second is the optimal
speed and any quicker than about three
centimeters per second you don't get the
same area of the brain lighting up
because quicker than three centimeters
per second wouldn't be fast enough for
you to be able to pick little bits of
whatever it is out of fur and they look
and they've done the same thing whilst
doing the primatology work and it's
exactly the same I really really I
hadn't heard that yeah that's in his new
one friends I did this book friends
really great so you mentioned there
about language something that you touch
on in your new one what's the
relationship between language and
thought I had this um lesson that I
learned a little while ago I think it's
uh Ludwig Wittgenstein and he says the
limits of my language mean the limits of
my world and I'd taken that to mean that
a richer vocabulary means a richer life
that basically the more precisely that I
can describe the things that have
occurred using the best kind of language
the Richer I get to experience it how
much bro science oh if I use that
no um
there's some claims of relationship
between language and thought which I
think are deep and important and true
like you know we could use language to
convey our thoughts which is what we're
doing now we use we could to some extent
um
the language we have reflects our
thoughts
um you know the only simple example is
by John McWhorter where he points out
that um that so many of our obscenities
have to do with God and Damnation and
sex and universally because these are
universally taboo and serious things a
deeper connection is that language like
language like English use the same
expressions for for space and time you
know I put the coin in my pocket uh I'll
do it in an hour so if you know I've got
a spatial thing language is all over uh
work on that model suggesting that
there's a deep relationship new space
and time in on how we think and this
gets conveyed by language
what isn't true or what doesn't seem to
be true
is the claim that the specific language
you learn affects how you think the very
popular idea
um that you know people who learn a
language like Navajo which might have a
different time system will think
differently from about time
people learn English versus French
versus Korean versus Urdu versus
whatever
um we'll think differently about the
world because of the structure language
and it turns out that whenever people
look at it it doesn't seem to be true
it seems to be that language that
language the language is all around the
world
um have the same sort of communicative
power and don't seem to seem to reflect
what we think but don't seem so much to
shape what we think given that a lot of
the time people think in words and the
words that they think in are in the
language that they're in what does the
fact that the language that you speak
doesn't seem to impact the things that
you think mean how do we Square this
circle
what's really interesting is and this
brings us back to what we're talking
about before we have a feeling we think
in words but we really can't in a way so
suppose you think you know I'm gonna go
play baseball because friends I gotta go
and buy a bat well the English word bat
is ambiguous
between you know the baseball bat and a
flying animal but your thought isn't
ambiguous
you know linguists like Lings like the
the ambiguous centers visiting relatives
can be boring which is ambiguous it
could mean when they visit you it's
boring or when you visit them it's
boring but it's not there's no ambiguity
when you think
so the idea we think in English
is I think to some extent the fact that
you do your thinking and you kind of
have a shadow
impression of English words that go with
it
but but you don't really think in
English in the same sense
you look unconvinced I just it's I'm
trying to I'm trying to work out I've I
don't speak another language I don't
know whether you do but I I only speak
English uh
and I've heard about people who speak
other languages sometimes dream in
different languages uh and that there's
I forget I saved a psychology today
article that uh the other week about
this something to do with
the
people who dream in different languages
it has some some kind of Downstream
psychological effect on them
um I just can't work out how
I'm so language heavy when it comes to
my thought yeah I I can't get myself
outside of what to me feel like the
thermodynamics of thinking you know yeah
so this is there is a tight band between
language and thought but here's how it
would go if you were also fluent in
Japanese
maybe you'd get to think in Japanese but
your thoughts wouldn't change
I mean I don't want to overstate it
sometimes languages have a flavor to
them in a sense that if you were raised
in Italy learned English as a second
language sometimes thinking and talking
in Italian will bring back certain
memories and feelings of the past while
English will get you in sort of another
mode
you know we do we do pick up
associations but the mental life of
somebody who thinks in Japanese is not
different to mental life if somebody
speaks in English
good yeah if if it was the world will be
a lot different than what it is each
language would essentially be a
different sort of species in a
psychological sense right yes does that
make sense yes I understand you've got
it nailed it right one of the biggest
differences between male and female
psychology
oh look at it has a lightning round feel
to it
um
the biggest difference between men and
women is that on average men are
sexually and romantically attracted to
women and on average women are sexually
attracted and don't have to attracted to
men that's the biggest difference you
know obviously it's not 100 a lot of men
are attracted to men a lot of men are
attracted to both a lot of men are
attracted to neither but the majority of
men are attracted to women that's that's
the biggest difference
when you get out of that
um the big differences have to do very
roughly
that man and this is this is of all the
sort of research I talk about in my book
surprisingly oh my God evolutionary
stuff you know that's very weak this
this is the sort of research it gets
done in 100 countries this is sort of
research we were talking before about
about the psychologist David Buss and
there's these enormous meta studies and
uh across different and you find big
cultural differences
but you always find the same sex
differences and the sex differences
typically are roughly
um men are more aggressive and
risk-taking and women are Kinder and
more nurtured
so and you don't have to go to a
psychology lab to see this you go
anywhere in the world and you say who
does more of your killing
Yes Man
women may be aggressive in other ways
they may be I don't want to make a cry
about who's verbally aggressive or
socially aggressive or whatever but pure
violence is mostly a male a male
activity
um the the care and nurturance of
children is mostly a female activity
and this is true for humans and it's
true for primates who are sort of
similar to humans now you always got to
have the caveat you're ended up talking
about occurs so everywhere in the world
is also true men are taller than women
this does not preclude the fact that
there are some women taller than average
man and some men shorter than the
average woman you kind of have whenever
time a human difference is maybe it's
worth putting in this caveat
there was a study I recently read what I
loved about it says all the continents
and just tons of nonsibilities of
enormous amount of people and it just
asks people a simple question
um how many sex partners you want to
have before you die
and in every in every country you look
at men want more than women
but the cool thing was
in addition to that is you've got
cultural differences so in some
countries like in some parts of the
world in Eastern Europe everything's
higher so men want a lot and women want
a lot in other cases and they say Africa
everything's lower
and the way it works is that women in
Eastern Europe want more sex partners
than men in Africa
so what you have is you have a sort of
what's it called one effect the main
effect of gender wherever you go men
want more than women but you also have
an effect of culture
in this place it's more than this place
and then you have cases where there's
this crossover where it affect the
culture is so big you have the cases
where where it kind of flips if you if
you compare it But to answer your
question
um issues like aggression risk-taking
um and then other aspects of sexual
preference typically men want want
younger Partners women care less about
age stuff like that yes the best example
I saw about the
um disposition let's say that uh males
would do war and women would do care
uh was from Joyce beninson and she spent
a ton of time with kindergarten kids and
she says if you look at the games that
three and four-year-olds play the boys
will find an enemy even if it's an
imaginary one it's aliens it's Cowboys
it's robbers it's whatever and the girls
will be keeping something alive that's
the way that that's what they tend to
lean toward and you know for all denial
of sex differences thing wants to happen
this is replicated in chimps you know
you give a a fluffy little sort of baby
chimp toy to a even slightly smaller
baby chimp and the same thing happens
there too
yeah and and I I think the stuff that
the basic difference is grounded in in
our evolutionary history people have
looked at cultures where more
egalitarian cultures you look like
Norway or Sweden those those countries
versus less egalitarian cultures like
country in the Middle East for instance
the effect is is in in shows up
everywhere in fact some of these sex
differences are bigger in more
egalitarian cultures
which might seem that seems so weird
you'd think that they would just
disappear in them the reason why they're
bigger is that if you're an egalitarian
society you're free to to sort of
Express whatever you want to do
and again the sort of overlapping bell
curves is worth is worth keeping in mind
as well as the fact that just because
something's sort of a natural tendency
um doesn't mean it's it's morally good
you know if some if someone would want
to be aggressive if some men want to be
nurtured I think people should be free
to do whatever whatever they want but
but this is the way the trend goes
do you think that attachment theory is
because I have been seeing this
more and more I have a bunch of friends
that work as coaches and therapists that
rely very heavily on attachment Theory
and whatnot
and I don't know how far it's getting
out over its skis have you looked at
attacking Theory
it's so funny you should say this I I
got into a discussion a few days ago
somebody a developmental scholar and I
said attachment theory is and
we argue back and forth and and
bullshit's too strong in that there are
um there are different attachment styles
parents and children have there's
different attachment Styles we could
have as adults
I think the strong claims about them are
I think in this domain as in so many
others people tend to forget base the
basics or principles of of how traits
get passed on from parents to children
so so the fact that um a child in a
certain attachment style as a kid might
duplicate that attachment style as an
adult need not be because of experience
it could be just from the get-go
it was maybe an aggressive parent or a
timid parent and it just got passed on
to the kid when you're saying that
you're not talking about a behaviorally
aggressive ultimate parent you're
talking about a genetically predisposed
yeah aggressive ultimate parent you're
talking about heritability and
behavioral genetics here yeah that's
right that's right but and even if you
so
I don't have any deep problem with
talking about attachment styles to say
that that's one style and that's another
style I think some of the claims about
them really do go go over the skus well
I'm
um I think in general one of the lessons
of a lot of research one of the more
again I keep talking about sort of
findings from psychology I think are a
little bit shocking you would expect
that the parents relationship to the kid
would have an enormous effect on that
what we grew up to be it's just it's
just common sense a loving parent makes
a kid later on loving says a brutal
parent you know traumatizes the kid
is not true as much as we think it is a
lot of the traits are just passed on
metagenes an environment doesn't matter
very much and to the extent environment
matters especially sometimes you know 50
60 40 whatever it doesn't seem to have
so much to do with parenting but more
experiences outside the home
so and what this means is that you take
uh parents and they have biological kids
and then they adopt kids into their
family and parenting played a huge role
you'd expect adopted kids to be very
much like the biological because they're
raised the same way it doesn't seem to
happen as much as it is and the extent
that attachment size get folded into
those sort of parenting arguments
parenting matters immensely for shaping
your personality and intelligence I
think there are problems with it
so would it be your view that attachment
style is uh less malleable you know for
instance personality your ocean Big Five
personality doesn't seem to change a
massive amount throughout your life you
you can there are a few interventions to
massively change that set point at least
compared with with other other things
um would you see attachment style kind
of folded in with with that kind of
predisposition I'd be tempted to think
that but I don't know I I would want to
be careful and want to look at this at
the studies
um you're you're right that for the most
part again putting aside our
personalities relatively constant over
our lifetime a kid who at age eight is
um is introverted and agreeable and
studious you know could be an adult most
likely lose introverted agreeable in
studious we can to some extent hack our
personalities
um people sometimes people do medication
if you're over anxious
um there are sometimes people people
claim that disciplines everything from
you know mindfulness meditation to
stoicism to Catholicism can transform
your personality in certain interesting
ways
but for the most part
doesn't change that much
you know I I sometimes think that this
is me not being a psychologist it's just
it's just just me thinking that the
trick to life
is in so much changing yourself but is
finding
um
friends lovers family
unemployment fun that mesh with how you
are
I'm I'm not an extroverted guy and I
could have tried to be extroverted more
extroverted but and be and then took
it'd be a Salesman but maybe I had ideas
I'm not a Salesman I'm a professor and
and could be a bit less introvert and
less extraverted and more focused on
other things
I really like that I really like that
takeaway especially as someone who
recently moved from a country where I
was felt a little discordant a little
bit like an off note and then to one now
where it feels a bit more aligned and I
have people around that I can understand
a little bit more and I went from a
career in a job that was incredibly
successful in and I took a ton of pride
in what we did running these massive
events and one of the biggest events
companies in the UK and all the rest of
it but again with that there was just
something a little bit it was you know
half an octave off and I thought what's
going on here uh and you know I'm now
doing something which again aligns with
my disposition with the way that I like
to live my life with the things I like
to think about in private in public yeah
uh and
yeah I I I totally agree if you
take
if you take it as
relative truth that the person that you
are is going to remain pretty constant
in terms of your your disposition
throughout your life that's not to say
that you can't change the kind of
capacities that you have and learn
things but your propensity toward
wanting to learn or wanting to be open
or wanting to change or wanting to be
neurotic or wanting to be extroverted
are going to stay the same you go okay
look these are kind of the physics of My
Universe
they're not absolute laws but they if I
try and fight against them they're going
to drag me back toward whatever they are
how can I get myself how can I marry
what I am with what I want to become
with what the world can deliver to me I
think that's a really nice way to fold
all of that together yeah I mean I I
like your example which is if you're in
the UK and you're kind of a natural
American
where you could try to stomp that aspect
of yourself out of you or you could do
what you didn't move to Texas you know
and I think there's an event it might be
easier to to move to Texas one thing to
keep in mind is implicit in all of this
is I think there are genuine there are
General ways to be that are bad that are
just maladaptive you know um that's you
that's slide into mental illness you
know nobody nobody wants to be
schizophrenic nobody wants to be
severely depressed nobody wants to be
incredibly anxious and for that you'd
want to fix it you're not gonna find a
world that's good that that that that
where you prosper in it but within a
surprising large range
there's just a lot of ways to be I was
talking about this in my intro Psych
class and student raise your hand and
asked me was a very good question saying
it's like what's the best personality
for for a reason what's what's the best
and it's a good question because a lot
of people think there's an answer to
this extroverted agreeable loner low
neuroticism
they're wrong actually that that in some
worlds being an extrovert is a real
power
in other lives being an extrovert is a
recipe for misery and failure an
introverts thrive
in some worlds it's really good to be
agreeable
everybody likes an agreeable person but
disagreeable person people you know
transform everything and so on and so
forth where where so it's not as if you
you you get yourself on a personality
skin he finds it oh I want to move here
here because that's the right way to be
rather there's a world and jobs and
people for just about every space in in
the personality Matrix
does that explain why people differ so
much in their intelligence and their
personality that there are or there
would have been a lot of different
environments and ways to succeed and if
we had pigeonholed every human to be
this much agreeable and this much
neurotic and this much whatever you
wouldn't have had uh as effective of a
tribe
that's really interesting
I don't know I've heard that sort of it
there's two ways of looking at it one is
any system is going to have noise why
isn't everybody exactly the same height
because there's just random stuff with
diet and genes and it pushes us around
and everything but it might well be that
in some ways some degree of human
variety
turns out to be adaptive and in some way
you don't have to talk sort of for the
good at a tribe A good group it's only a
sort of frequency dependent where if if
everybody if enough people in my Society
are A's it might pay to be a b
and then once you get enough B's and
they overwhelm you might pay to be an a
if if there's enough of people are are
uh agreeable a disagreeable person could
clean up
whenever people are disagreeable an
agreeable person oh yeah everybody wants
to be with them and so in this way in a
sort of dynamic one could imagine that
that there's been a variety turns out to
be to be beneficial it's like a
personality arms race in a way yes yes
finding different different ways to come
through I mean considering some other
sort of sort of market like consider you
know TV shows why doesn't everybody make
the same great TV show because if you
have 10 Prestige dramas all of a sudden
uh uh a dirty lowbrow comedy is for
everybody oh my god let's see that what
a break from it and then when you get
enough of those you toss in some reality
shows you're gonna have to do and then
you get a range of things
because in this world
um sometimes you sometimes you're sort
of negative adverse selection to being
the way everyone else is
my we've just touched on behavioral
genetics there I had Robert Plowman on
the show maybe a year and a half ago two
years ago and the guy's phenomenal and I
I love his work
I feel like if I was to look at the
field of science at the moment not diet
but sort of psychology and and personal
development style stuff the biggest hole
in terms of public education the longest
lever that we could push down on would
be teaching people about how behavioral
genetics Works about how heritability
works I think that
that would help people to make Better
Life Choices better partner choices it
would help parents to feel less culpable
or uh less neurotic and over concerned
about the outcomes that their kids are
going to have and then when you fold in
the you know the the nurture part of the
nature nurture debate isn't the nurture
that you give them it's the nurture that
Jim's dad next door gives them and it's
the nurture of the boxing coach that
they give them and the friends that are
around them that they impart impart on
them I feel like that
from the outside looking in is the
biggest hole that we have in terms of
sort of public education
I think that's a
I think that's that that's that that
that's a wise point I'll just add two
things one is as you notice that gets
very politicized
um and you know talk about genes and
behaviors and everything for some people
it brings up a specter of scientific
racism and you know Holocaust and all of
that stuff so so I think now we're
starting to sort of say well we could
sensibly talk about these things
without um without it being care of the
ugly baggage of History just like you
know behaviorism other other ideas of
human nature similarly have an ugly
baggage of of control and totalitarian
governments and everything I think we're
going to look at the facts in some in a
way that's compassionate and reason the
other thing is at some level it's just
stuff worth getting out but at another
level when people aren't on Twitter or
Facebook or writing op-eds and
everything people kind of know there's
some really nice stuff done by Emily
Willoughby where she just asks people
from a scale of 0 to 100 how heritable
are these different traits you know how
your your introversion aggression
religiousness sexual orientation
eye color and so on explains a little
bit what this means and then graphs it
it turns out your average person is not
bad
and knowing this your average person
pretty much matches with some exceptions
the scientific literature
when when you're not dealing with people
who are ideologues and you ask people
say do you think how
shy somebody is
is sort of a genetic trait people often
appreciate it yeah it is to some extent
there was a chart in plowman's book
blueprint and I think that that's the
same study that we were talking about
yeah well I had a a guy on talking about
embryo selection and genetic enhancement
uh Johnny anomaly talking about this
recently and that I think will force
everybody it will be a very difficult to
avoid red pill for everybody about
heritability because as soon as you can
go in and say well look this is
these are the um raw materials that
we're playing with and this is how far
we can push these different things and
downstream from that look at the changes
that children have from genetic
interventions before they were born yeah
it kind of bursts this conversation open
a little bit and that technology is not
slowing down it's not stopping it seems
like it's it's partly already here and
in the future is only going to be more
here I think that's right but I'll give
you something which is here and I
haven't looked into this but here's my
intuition many many people have kids
through uh uh donor sperm and donor eggs
I don't think there's many people who
say I don't care it's all it's all have
you already send me get me anybody's
sperm anybody's ex I'm in no people
really want the sperm and eggs a people
they see as having you know not just
good physical health but they haven't
had a history of severe mental illness
they want people who are Nobel Prize
winners they want they want women who
have been to the to the Ivy Leagues they
want people who are and and I think
when push comes to shove people have an
understanding that
um that this stuff matters
you know what's very interesting there I
don't know whether you've considered
this but Johnny taught me about this
when it comes to sperm donor selection
criteria for women what you get to do
as a woman is bypass your own mating
psychology
with regards to what you're attracted to
in terms of what seduces you which may
cause you to Downstream use those
genetics to form a child and what you
actually do is you optimize for the
traits that you want your child to have
independent of the attraction so a lot
of the time like a a pleasant
disposition or kindness uh is something
that is really really optimized for
being like dominance and stuff which may
be something which is sexually
attractive but in a child do I want like
a super dominant child well perhaps not
and that was the first time that I've
ever thought oh my God look at what
happens when you can separate out having
sex from the production of the child
that comes from it or or attraction from
uh procreation
it's really interesting you know there's
this work and I bet you're familiar with
this on what's attractive so you take an
average face average faces are pretty
attractive because you factor out all
the flaws and everything and imagine you
know maybe genetic heterogeneity would
have been pretty great for female faces
if you dial up the femininity of the
face
everybody thinks they're prettier make
the eyes bigger makes lips Fuller and
prettier but for male faces if you dial
up the masculinity it doesn't quite do
it you see these fake these fishes these
testosterone dies you know the enormous
jaw and like that and and you know and
in some cases they're considered worse
and there you're capturing what you just
said which is for women there's sort of
two things that pull apart which is you
may not want a hyper aggressive most
manly man
um there's there's a draw to that but
you also want a man with actually some
female crates some protibly female who
isn't as aggressive who is more
compassioned more kind and so so the
case for for women selecting that isn't
that as simple and you're exactly right
in a case where you could separate what
you want as a kit for your kit and what
you want for your partner there's is a
separation when one will adopt
do you think that psychology can help us
understand what a good life is
I think the question of what the good
life is is not ultimately a
psychological question it's it is a
moral and philosophical question you
know if one psychologist said a good
life is simple simple pleasure Hedonism
maximize you know not of of heatons
amount of of orgasms and cookies and all
that stuff this that's the good life and
another one said no no a good life is
being moral and relationships and
suffering look at an experiment to
figure out which is right there's a a
philosophical disagreement here I think
the second guy is right actually but but
it's not it's not a psychological
question where psychology comes in as
once you decide what a good life is what
to maximize a psychologist can tell you
a little bit about how to get there then
it becomes empirical question
you know if um so so I've been
interested in the question for instance
if do children make you happy
and
I I don't the question of whether it's
good to have children is some sort of
abstract way is not a psychological but
what's the effect of people's lives on
having children
an answer actually turns out is
complicated it depends it's different
for men than for women it's in countries
with good child dig into that explain
um so the original finding studies were
done by by Conor in the United States
and they found that um they use an
experienced sampling thing where they
took uh where it turned out that peoples
who had kids were on a whole less happy
than people without kids and when they
were with their kids they're kind of
stressful it wasn't a good time
and so the argument was being having
kids doesn't make you happy
but then there were more studies then
and the answer is always with these
things is it depends
um in countries which have good child
care
parents tend to be happier than
non-parents if the United States isn't
only atypical and that's a very wealthy
country but doesn't have very good paid
child care
um younger parents are in some way less
happy than older parents single parents
as you can imagine find the period where
their kids are young to be very
difficult
um women sometimes find it a bit harder
than them
to me the most interesting findings
comes when you separate the questions of
how much pleasure you're getting from
your kid how happy does your kid make
day to day and how worthwhile do you
think it is how meaningful do you think
it is because then when you ask about
meaning and worthwhileness of value
significance you do find that there's a
real significance to having kids
and for me you know I I have I have two
sons in their 20s and and actually you
know I actually really like raising them
so I mean it's just not a complicated
thing but in some way if people say so
what do you think of having kids I
wouldn't say it really add a lot of
pleasure to my life seems like the wrong
way of doing it it's just it it is of
great significance I love them they're
they're they're the most important thing
I ever did
separate from any happiness they gave me
I remember learning about Kahneman and
Dan Gilbert and they had two different
conceptions of of happiness it may have
even been from you the night from The
Sweet Spot I I actually I I had the
debate yes yes and one was uh Hedonism
and the other is meaning and one is uh
you spend the entire the remainder of
your life on a
Lilo with a cocktail in a pool sunning
yourself and the other one you do
difficult things but in retrospect
you're glad that you did them it's my
belief upon reflecting on your book from
two years ago that I forgot it was from
your book that
your personal disposition
is one of the most important
determinants as to how you move up and
down on that Spectrum so if you are the
kind of person that ruminates that's
introspective that will tend to uh
reflect and and consider your decisions
perhaps a little bit more that will seek
the meaning in things I don't know where
on Ocean
Hedonism lies maybe like openness to new
experience or so I don't know but anyway
my point being if you are the the
non-hedonistic person you need to
optimize for things that are going to
give you meaning
whereas if you're someone that does can
take more simple pleasure in the
moment-to-moment experience of life then
perhaps you also need to factor that in
too how far off do you think I am
I don't think you're far off at all I
think that I'm a pluralist and I think
there's a lot of things you might want
to maximize in your life you know
meaning pleasure we haven't talked about
being a good person being moral we
haven't heard of a spirituality present
people and everybody got to choose how
you rank them how you prioritize them
and I think you're exactly right that
some people be more comfortable with one
choice over another some people like to
be challenged some people don't
um I think for everybody though The
Simple Pure Hedonism plan is probably
not a good idea
even on its own terms
like suppose we both say my gosh all
that matters is happiness but we could
agree on that but still say but don't
try to be happy
so for one thing you get bored if you're
just happy all the time happiness you
get a the so-called hedonic treadmill if
it's going to get bored of stuff
but for another there's actually some
nice studies finding that at least for
people in uh in the west east is a
little bit different
you ask them how important is it for you
to be happy and then you ask them how
happy they are and there's a negative
correlation people put value and
importance on happiness tend to be less
happy now immediately somebody like you
so yeah it's complicated because you can
imagine the criticism being if you're
less happy maybe you take happiness more
seriously so it's hard to pull them
apart but I think in general trying to
be happy this is this is ancient wisdom
it's kind of a sucker's move and what
you should try to do is maximize other
things and then happiness will come
along if you're lucky or do it right for
the right
looking forward given that we are now uh
perhaps there's more
areas of research to be decapitated by
the replication process but
uh looking forward what do you think are
some areas of psychology that are the
the unknowns or the unknown unknowns
where where are we why should
psychologists be looking at what what
can people expect do you think from
psychology over the next couple of
decades
wow that's such a good question
I think in ways that I find it hard to
anticipate I think that the rise of AI
over the last very recent past last year
or so six months What's Happening Now
chat EPT is going to transform
psychology
in certain ways
um
I know people and I'm actually involved
in one project where we're testing
people to get their intuitions we're
also testing chat gbt we want to know
what it thinks too with an eye towards
pulling apart what a statistical
learning machine would do and what a
person would do so I feel that that's a
very rich area
I'll tell you something another area
just to just to kind of mix it up a bit
there's one part of psychology which is
sort of punched below its weight and
it's clinical
clinicals like I've heard experts in the
field expert clinicians say over the
last 30 years there's been no big
developments in Clinical Psychology we
know treatment works but it's not like
the treatment works better now than it
did in 1990. medications work drugs work
but you know we got Prozac we got we got
you know Lorazepam we got his do you
think they're not very different from
what was on the market 20 years ago
I wonder if that's going to change
there's a lot of interest in
psychedelics
a lot of interesting like mindfulness
meditation there's a lot of new ideas a
lot of interest in um in sort of
neuroscientific interventions involving
sort of basically zapping the brain in
different ways and it wouldn't surprise
me if we're on on the cusp of the
Revolution understanding mental illness
that would be pretty cool that would be
really cool ladies and gentlemen I
really appreciate your work I absolutely
love it the new one Psych is great why
should people go if they want to check
out the stuff that you do and keep up to
date with your work
um I got I got a website paulbloom.net
and I got a Twitter thing Paul Bloom at
you and um and in both of them I I
mercilessly uh try to try to impose this
until at one point in Twitter they're
gonna say stop doing this We're not
gonna follow you anymore so I gotta stop
you're no longer a Twitter account
you're just a Salesman and just a
Salesman and everything so so but that's
where to find me thank you so much this
is always this is always a lot of fun
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]